كثير اوقات نحس ان الشهر طويل يعني شهر
مايو رمضان العيد رمضان العيد رمضان
والعيد
في في ولا
بس بخلص العيد
خاصه اذا يعني
يصادف انه الراتب خلص بسرعه هذا هذا شيء
تحس بانه الشهر قاعد يمر سنه
شهر مايو انا بحس كمان شهر يناير كمان
طويل جدا لكن شهر مايو الحالي اطلق عليه
سنه مايو الكبيسه وهو تعبير ساخر يتداوله
ناشطون عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
للاشاره الى الشارع الذي نشعر بانه الاطول
في السنه هذا الاحساس بطوله شهر سواء كان
مايو او حتى غيره من الاشهر يفسره العلماء
باكثر من سبب منها المتغيرات اللي يشهدها
سواء على المستوى العام او الخاص بالنسبه
للافراد كذلك تغير الفصول النهار يكون
اطول في الصيف من الشتاء طبعا والحاله
العاطفيه طبعا للشخص والنشاط الفعلي له
يلعبان ايضا دورا كبيرا في الاحساس بمرور
الوقت اضافه الى توقع وانتظار شيء ما سوف
يحدث في المستقبل ما يجعل الايام تمر ببطء
يمكن لانه احنا منتظرين الاجازه الصيفيه
عشان هيك شهر ماي اربع سنين طوله لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات